hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
moin mein Name ist Natalie Strauß ich
bin Radiomoderatorin und damit
normalerweise im Hier und Jetzt
verhaftet doch heute nimmt Sprecher und
Moderatoren Mirko Kasimir und ich euch
mit auf einer Reise in die Vergangenheit
mehr als 2000 Jahre geht es heute zurück
und zwar ins Jahr 44 vor Christus in die
Eden des März und den Schauplatz das
wahrscheinlich berühmtesten politischen
Attentats vielleicht abgesehen vom Mord
an John F Kennedy ja es geht um den Mord
an Gajus Julius Caesar moin Mirko hallo
Natalie und du hast recht der Fall
Julius Caesar das ist ein richtiger
Klopper da gibt's zum einen natürlich
die Geschichte die Story an sich und die
die hat schon alles was ein Bestseller
oder Blockbuster braucht eine
Verschwörung verharrt wie alle kennen
den Namen Brutus eine Falle und düstere
Omen und auch eine Lovestory hallo die
darf natürlich auch nicht fehlen und das
ist eine der berühmtesten Affären der
Geschichte Caesar und Kleopatra okay das
hat jetzt nicht mit dem Mord zu tun aber
hat auf jeden Fall auch ihren Anteil auf
dem Weg dahin auf jeden Fall dann ist da
die historische Dimension dieses Falles
der Aufstieg und falls Cäsars markiert
das Ende der römischen Republik und dem
Beginn des römischen Reiches und damit
kommen wir zu einer dritten Dimension
der Frage welche Lehren wir vielleicht
aus den Ereignissen damals ziehen können
wie wird aus einer Republik mit Macht
und Gewaltenteilung eine monokratie ein
Staat in dem alle Macht von einer Person
ausgeht
da ist auf jeden Fall einiges los wir
uns sicherlich die meisten Hörer und
Hörerinnen sind keine geschichtsexperten
deshalb Mirko einmal ganz kurzes Update
bitte was war da gleich noch mal los
bereits in Rom
ich erzähls mal am besten anhand der
Lebensgeschichte von Julius Gajus Cäsar
er wurde am 13 Juli des Jahres 100 vor
Christus geboren kleine radnotiz der
Juli hieß damals nicht juli sondern
quintilles erst in Caesars Todesjahr 44
vor Christus wurde sein Geburtsmonat ihm
zu Ehren in Julius umbenannt
Caesar entstammte dem Patricia
Geschlecht der Julia die Abstammung bis
auf die Göttin Venus zurückführten als
junger Mann geriet Cäsar in Konflikt mit
Lucius Cornelius Zula der damals als
Diktator über Rom herrschte
Caesar musste die Stadt verlassen und
machte Karriere in der Armee
das Wort Diktator das müssen wir
übrigens ganz kurz erklären dass wir
unsere Geschichte ziemlich wichtig ist
und damals eine etwas andere Bedeutung
hatte also in kriegs- und Krisenzeiten
ernannte man in der Republik einen
Diktator diesen wurde dann praktisch die
Alleinherrschaft übertragen das
besondere daran ist aber seine Ernennung
war zeitlich begrenzt auf maximal sechs
Monate auf keinen Fall sollte sich auf
seiner Diktatur dann auch eine
dauerhafte Herrschaft entwickeln
500 Jahre zuvor war der letzte römische
König davon gejagt und die Republik
wurde errichtet die Abneigung gegen die
Monarchie war also fest verwurzelt sola
war der erste der versuchte diese
aufzuweichen und seine Amtszeit als
Diktator zu verlängern er trat aber auch
schließlich freiwillig zurück so wie
alle anderen Diktatoren vor ihm leider
ist das ein bisschen aus der Mode
geraten ja unter den aktuellen
Diktatoren das können wir mal wieder
einführen aber Mirko erzählt du erstmal
wieder weiter
78 vor Christus nach soll das Abdankung
als Diktator begann Caesars politische
Karriere in Rom und erregte schnell
Aufsehen und die Aufmerksamkeit
mächtiger Feinde die politische Klasse
war damals tief gespalten auf der einen
Seite standen die popularis denen sich
Caesar zugehörig fühlte und die sich auf
die Volksversammlung stützten sei es aus
politischem Kalkül man würde sie heute
wohl Populisten nennen oder aus echtem
Interesse an den Belangen des Volkes auf
der anderen Seite die Optimaten die
Vertreter des konservativen Adels zu
denen auch Zulage gehörte
um der Feindschaft zulass aus dem Weg zu
gehen verließ Caesar Rom erneut und
begab sich auf eine Studienreise nach
Rhodos
da ist allerdings nie angekommen weil er
unterwegs von Piraten gekippt ne wurde
die wiederum ein Lösegeld für seine
Freilassung verlangten Caesar war
darüber richtig wütend wie man sich
natürlich vorstellen kann allerdings
nicht aus offensichtlichen Gründen was
ihn besonders wütend machte war nicht
die Tatsache an sich sondern dass sie
Piraten wohl zu wenig Lösegeld forderten
er war der Meinung er sei deutlich mehr
wert und hat die Piraten dann
tatsächlich überzeugt die Summe
herauszusetzen so hat das zumindest
selber später berichtet
nach seiner Freilassung organisierte er
eine private Seestreitmacht jagte und
fing die Piraten ein und ließ sie
allesamt kreuzigen
Caesar kehrte erneut nach Rom zurück
setzte seine politische Laufbahn fort
und wurde schließlich in den Senat
aufgenommen und das Jahr 67 vor Christus
heiratete er seine Frau pompeia eine
Enkelin ausgerechnet seines alten
Feindes zu LAH die Ehe hielt nur ein
paar Jahre
im Jahr 62 vor Christus erschütterte ein
Riesenskandal die römische Republik in
dem es um die Fruchtbarkeitsgöttin bona
dea einen Mann in Frauenkleidern und
entweihte Kultobjekte ging lange
Geschichte
im Zuge dessen kamen Gerüchte auf pompea
hätte ein Verhältnis mit eben jenem Mann
und Frauenkleidern Publius Clodius
pulcher gehabt und Caesar trennte sich
von mir nicht weil er an die Affäre
glaubte sondern so sagte er es Caesars
Frau muss frei von jedem Verdacht sein
bitte was ist das denn bitte für eine
Logik oh ich muss dich leider verlassen
weil andere schlecht über dich denken
könnten
tja
Caesar wurde Statthalter in Spanien wo
er große militärische Erfolge gegen die
Aufständischen lusitaner erringen konnte
er kehrte nach Rom zurück und bewarb
sich für das Amt eines Konsums das
Konsulat war übrigens das höchste
römische Amt die Konsulen standen dem
Senat vor und waren die militärischen
Oberbefehlshaber da gab es dann auch
strenge Regeln um zu verhindern dass
sich aus dem Konsulat eine
Alleinherrschaft oder Gott bewahre sogar
eine Monarchie entwickeln konnte somit
war die Amtszeit auf ein Jahr begrenzt
und es gab immer zwei Konsolen um sich
die Macht zu teilen aber Mirko ich
glaube wir müssen einen kleinen Zahn
zulegen oder klar machen wir
59 vor Christus wurde Caesar endlich zum
konsulberufen und begann die römische
Politik umzukrempeln er überschritt
seine Befugnisse hielt sich nicht ein
Regeln machte sich aber mit Brot und
Spielen beim Volk extrem beliebt
nach seinem sicherheitskonsul ginge als
Statthalter nach Gallien eroberte
riesige Gebiete drang bis ans rechte
reinufer und nach Britannien vor im Jahr
50 vor Christus kehrte er nach Italien
zurück sein Ziel war es seine ungeheure
Popularität im Volk zu nutzen um sich
erneut zum Konsul wählen zu lassen
seine Gegner wollten das um jeden Preis
verhindern und ihn vor Gericht stellen
sie forderten ihn auf die Waffen
niederzulegen und das Kommando über
seine Legionen abzugeben
keine Option für Caesar am 10 Januar 49
vor Christus überschritten Caesar und
seine treu ergebene Legion den Rubicon
die Würfel waren gefallen die bewaffnete
Überquerung dieses Grenzflusses zwischen
den Nordprovinzen und dem eigentlichen
Italien war eine Kriegserklärung gegen
den römischen Senat es kam zu einem
langen blutigen Bürgerkrieg aus dem
Caesar dann schließlich als Sieger
hervorging seinen erbitterten Feind
pompeos verfolgte er dann sogar bis nach
Alexandria wo er wiederum Bekanntschaft
von Kleopatra machte und die legendäre
Affäre der beiden begann
nach seiner Rückkehr nach Rom
ähm ich habe den Eindruck dass ich
diesen Satz heute schon ein paar mal
gesagt habe
Caesar was für ein Hin und Her nach
seiner triumphalen Rückkehr nach Rom
wurde Caesar zum Diktator auf zehn Jahre
lang ein krasser Bruch mit allen
Traditionen der die Befürchtungen
wachsen ließ er wolle sich zum König
machen
im Februar 44 vor Christus ging er noch
einen Schritt weiter er ließ sich zum
Diktator perpeto zum Diktator auf
Lebenszeit ändern
außerdem ließ er sich einen goldenen
Thron aufstellen und seine Statue ins
pantium den Schrein der Götter
transportieren ein König um Himmels
willen ich doch nicht Gott passt schon
eher zu mir man kann also verstehen dass
das seine Gegner nicht wirklich
überzeugte und so begann eine Gruppe von
Verschwörern seine Ermordung zu planen
unter ihnen Markus Junius Brutus
Brutus gehörte zu Cäsars engstem
Freundeskreis für den Diktator war er
beinahe wie ein Sohn oder war er
vielleicht sogar sein Sohn
Brutus Mutters Servilia war eine der
Geliebten Caesar gewesen auch zeitlich
passen diese Beziehung und Brutus Geburt
gut zusammen aber sei es wie es sei
Caesar war Brutus ein väterlicher Freund
und vertraute ihm
Brutus selbst führt seine Abstammung auf
Lucius Julius Bruder zurück eine
legendäre Gestalt die der Sage nach im
Jahr 59 vor Christus den letzten
römischen König vertrieben und die
Republik gegründet hatte
dieses Erbe bestärkte Brutus in seinem
Willen Caesars Herrschaft zu beenden und
so hoffte er die Republik zu retten
mehr als 60 Senatoren waren schließlich
in den Plan eingeweiht und der Plan war
einfach auf der letzten Szene hat
Sitzung vor seiner Abreise zu einem
neuen Feldzug sollte Caesar mit Dolchen
getötet werden da nur Senatorin Zugang
hatten und seine Leibwächter ihn daher
nicht würden schützen können wäre er den
Attentätern hilflos ausgeliefert
am Abend vor dem Attentat speiste Caesar
im Haus seines Freundes dieser fragte
ihn der Überlieferung zufolge welchen
Tod er für den besten halte
Caesar soll geantwortet haben der
unerwartete
am nächsten Tag sollte Caesar seinen
bevorzugten Tod sterben obwohl er nur
für ihn unerwartet kam und keinesfalls
unangekündigt
Caesar hatte zahllose Warnungen bekommen
ein sehr warnte ihn vor den Iden des
März
Eden des März noch so ein berühmter
Begriff wir benutzen den Begriff nur im
Plural aber eigentlich sind die Eden nur
ein Tag in jedem Monat entweder der 13
oder der 15 die ihnen das März meint den
15.3
etwas Schreckliches würde in den Iden
des März Geschehen er habe es in den
Eingeweiden gelesen und Caesar solle
sein Haus nicht verlassen seine Frau
kalt purnier die trotz seiner
öffentlichen Liebschaft zu Kleopatra
treu zu ihm stand hatte in der Nacht
schreckliche Albträume und sah düsterer
Omen es heißt Caesar habe daraufhin
tatsächlich erwogen der Senatssitzung
fern zu bleiben
man muss dazu wissen dass er ohnehin
nicht viel vom Sinn hat hielt und von
dem was am politischen Theater noch von
der Republik übrig war außerdem fühlte
er sich unwohl manchen Quellen zufolge
aufgrund eines Katers offenbar wurde
beim Essen und über den besten Tod reden
im Haus des Freundes wohl auch
ordentlich gebächert
die Verschwörer schickten Brutus zu
Cäsar und es gelang ihm davon zu
überzeugen doch teilzunehmen es heißt er
habe sich darüber lustig gemacht dass
Caesar etwas auf die düsteren Ahnungen
einer Frau gäbe und so machte sich
Caesar auf den Weg zum Theater des
pompeus in dem die Sitzung des Senats
stattfinden sollte unterwegs traf er auf
den Seher der ihn vor den Iden des März
gewarnt hatte und sagte die ihnen des
März sind da
da sind sie aber noch nicht vorbei
antwortete der düster
ebenfalls aus dem Weg zum Theater
erreichte Caesar eine Schriftrolle die
Details der Verschwörung enthielt
doch er übergab sie einen Mitglied
seines Stabes um sie dann später zu
lesen doch das mit dem später wurde
nichts mehr verzähler
seine letzte Chance verstrich direkt vor
dem Theater sein Freund Markus Antonius
hatte von den Attentatsplänen erfahren
und versuchte Caesar zu warnen doch die
Verschwörer konnten ihn aufhalten und
Caesar tappte in die Falle
das Theater ist gut gefüllt
600 Senatorin sind anwesend und die
meisten von ihnen sind ahnungslos
kurz nach dem Caesar den Senat betreten
hat tritt Senator tilius Zimmer an ihn
heran
vorgeblich um eine Petition zu
überreichen die die Verbannung seines
Bruders aufheben soll
Caesar winkt ihn ungeduldig Weg er hat
keine Zeit und keine Interesse doch
statt sich zurückzuziehen greift Zimba
nach Caesars Toga sieht sie herunter und
entblößt seine Schulter Caesar schreit
auf das ist der Gewalt
doch es ist nur der Auftakt zur Gewalt
der Startschuss für einen Mord das unter
den Verschwörern verabredete Zeichen sie
haben sich längst unauffällig um ihn
versammelt jetzt greifen Sie nach den
Dolchen die sie unter ihren Drogen
verborgen in das Theater geschmuggelt
haben den ersten Streich führt Senator
servilius kaska von hinten sticht der
Cäsar in den Nacken
der fährt herum greift den Arm des
Attentäters cascal du Schurke was tust
du ruft er so berichtet es später der
Geschichtsschreiber brutarch und kaska
schreit um Hilfe im nächsten Augenblick
stechen sie alle auf ihn ein Cäsar
versucht zu entkommen doch er ist schon
schwer verletzt blind vom Blut das ihm
in die Augen sind er stolpert und fällt
bedeckt das Gesicht mit seiner Toga
während die Attentäter weiter auf ihn
einstechen
auch du Brutus sind seine letzten Worte
oder so ähnlich laut anderen Quellen
sagt er etwas in der Art von auch du
Kind was als Beleg für die These vom
illegitiven Sohn genommen wird andere
Bericht nerve gar nichts mehr gesagt
fest steht Caesar war tot sein Körper
von 23 Messerstichen getroffen
nach der Tat marschierten die Attentäter
zum Capitol und riefen Volk von Rom wir
sind wieder frei
doch statt es erwarteten Jubels schlug
ihnen eisiges Schweigen entgegen
Caesars Beerdigung war ein letzter
großer Triumph über die Attentäter das
Volk von Rom betrauerte einen Helden die
ganze Sache geriet etwas außer Kontrolle
als immer mehr Menschen herantränken und
das Feuer das Caesars Leichnam verzehren
sollte mit trockenen Zweigen Möbeln und
Kleidungsstücken fütterten
Veteran in seiner Legionen warfen ihre
Waffen in die Flammen Frauen warfen
ihren Schmuck ins Feuer das Forum
Romanum wurde ernsthaft in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen
und die römische Republik war so tot wie
der Mann vor dem die Attentäter sie
retten wollte es folgte ein 13-Jähriger
Bürgerkrieg und an dessen Ende stand das
römische Reich unter der Herrschaft des
ersten Kaisers das ersten Cäsaren
Augustus
niemand kann sagen wie die Geschichte
ohne Cäsars Ermordung verlaufen wäre
hätte er eines Tages doch noch sein Amt
niedergelegt und die verfassungsmäßige
Ordnung wiederhergestellt und
wahrscheinlich klar ist jedenfalls dass
die Verschwörer zwar ihr unmittelbares
Ziel das Ermordung erreichten ihr
eigentliches Ziel aber vollkommen
verfehlten spannend ist auch keiner von
Caesars Mördern überlebte ihn länger als
drei Jahre sie wurden von Caesar
Getreuen ermordet begingen Selbstmord
einige starben in Schlachten
der Tyrann ist tot hier ist es später
aber die Tyrannei lebt
[Musik]
ja und damit sind wir fast am Ende Mirko
was macht die Geschichte mit dir
naja wir haben ja schon zu Anfang die
vielen Dimensionen dieses Falls
aufgezählt aber es ist wohl ein
politischer Mord wie es ihnen häufig in
der Geschichte gab doch heute noch es
ist wirklich erstaunlich wie diese ganze
Geschichte Nachhalt immerhin kennt jeder
der sich auch nur ein bisschen für
Geschichte interessiert die Namen Caesar
Brutus Kleopatra und jeder kennt die
Zitate den Rubikon überschreiten die
Würfel sind gefallen oder auch du Brutus
diese Geschichte steckt ganz tief im
Fundament der abendländischen Kultur und
dann ist er eben noch die Sache mit den
Lehrern die man daraus ziehen kann ne
oder eben halt nicht was mich da
beeindruckt ist diese ja fast schon
Naivität mit der die Verschwörer da
answerke gegangen sind wenn nur ca weg
ist dann ist sie Republik gerettet aber
so einfach ist das ja nicht es gibt ja
heute oft auch diesen Gedanken wenn nur
dieser oder Jena autokrath Weg wäre dann
wäre das Problem gelöst aber solange die
Ursachen beseitigt sind ist alles gar
nicht mal so einfach also ist glaube ich
die wichtigste Lektion es ist alles gar
nicht so einfach und Mord ist auch
überhaupt gar keine Lösung da gebe ich
dir auf jeden Fall recht Maut kann nie
eine Lösung sein ich glaube darauf
können wir uns auf jeden Fall einigen ja
liebe Podcast Hörerinnen und Hörer
vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit wir
hoffen es hat euch gefallen und ihr seid
auch beim nächsten Mal wieder mit dabei
bei Tatort Deutschland Spezial macht's
gut und immer dran denken auf die eigene
Frau hören kann Leben retten
und eure Natalie
für unsere Schilderung dieser antiken
Geschichte haben wir unter anderem einen
Artikel der Welt eine Ausgabe der
ZDF-Reihe Terra x sowie die Portale das
römische Reich und wissen.de genutzt
außerdem via Wikipedia das Schriftstück
von Dan cullin Hardcore history
deathrows of the Republic series sowie
den Podcast von Mike danken the history
of Rom
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Heyer Produktion Marvin schwarz